but when it comes to coffee i gotta have
coffee tell me the the good and the bad
i don't think coffee is as bad as some
people present it to be i think it's
really the timing of the coffee
consumption so for example we're
recording this at at one o'clock pacific
standard time i would definitely not
advise you have coffee after this point
in the day um now if you're gonna go do
a hard workout if you're like oh my gosh
i haven't seen my girlfriends in like
three months we're gonna go out tonight
find a little caffeine but caffeine
really is problematic for
helping you fall asleep it you know
disturbs
all the adenosine metabolism in the
brain but i'm a fan especially you know
we were talking before we started
recording about maybe a wedding's coming
up losing a little weight you know a lot
of people have you know these want to
get in shape for summer using caffeine
before you exercise has been shown to
prevent the catabolism or the breakdown
of muscle which is a good thing and
enhance the oxidation of fat so uh in
the morning i'm a big fan of that